[Musique]
cher francilienne cher franciliens il ya
six ans vous m'avez élu à la présidence
de la région ile de france une région
pleine de contrastes de défis et de
promesses une région qui rayonne à
travers l'europe et le monde
il ya six ans je n'ai fait engagé à
remettre l'île de france sur les rails
de l'efficacité de la bonne gestion et
de l'action concrète au quotidien depuis
six ans je suis une présidente de région
à plein-temps 100% tournée là les
franciliennes et les franciliens comme
je m'y étais engagé depuis six ans je
n'ai jamais cessé de me mobiliser et de
me battre aussi pour vous défendre vous
protéger et pour rendre notre région
plus belle plus unis plus sûrs et plus
justes
aujourd'hui je regarde le chemin
parcouru et quel chemin
nous avons lancé la révolution des
transports avec 659 et rénové là où à
l'époque tout le monde nous disait que
c'était impossible
nous avons accéléré la transition
écologique avec une écologie positive
qui encourage qui entreprend plutôt qu
une écologie qui punit qui sanctionne et
qui divise nous avons déployé un
bouclier de sécurité pour renforcer
votre protection dans les transports les
lycées et dans vos communes
nous avons été pionniers en matière de
défense des valeurs de la république et
de la laïcité en instaurant une charte
de la laïcité
avec un principe simple pas d'argent
public pour les ennemis de la république
nous avons engagé un plan d'urgence pour
les lycées le 6 milliards d'euros pour
rénover les établissements que nous
avons malheureusement trouvait dans un
état de vétusté préoccupant après des
années de sous investissement
nous nous sommes puissamment engagé
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
pour vous soutenir et vous protéger en
fournissant des masques des tests en
aidant les jeunes en soutenant le
soignant nos entreprises et nos
commerces et en défendant vos emplois et
votre pouvoir d'achat
oui nous avons engagé
le plan de relance régional le plus
ambitieux de france car j'ai la
conviction qu'ensemble nous pouvons
relever plus fort de cette crise
je suis fier du chemin parcouru et je
suis convaincu qu'il reste encore
beaucoup à faire beaucoup pas inventé
pour garder le cap que nous avons
impulsé le cap de la sécurité et des
valeurs de la république le cas de
l'écologie des résultats et le cap de
l'égalité des chances mais nous devons
donner un nouvel élan un nouveau souffle
c'est ce programme très ambitieux que je
vous propose
car mon rôle c'est de vous protéger de
vous aider à mieux vivre de vous aider à
réussir et à vous relever mon rôle c'est
de vous garantir que vous serez traités
avec une égale dignité
quel que soit votre origine votre
identité ou votre territoire urbain ou
rural
oui j'aime l'île de france et je veux
continuer à me battre au quotidien pour
chaque francilien me battre pour vous de
toutes mes forces
[Musique]